the last few months have weighed heavily
on the German government the coalition
almost fell apart there's been violence
and hatred on the streets of Germany and
the domestic intelligence chief was
accused of going soft on the far-right
my guest this week here in Strasbourg is
David McAllister he's chair of the
European Parliament's Foreign Affairs
Committee and a former regional prime
minister in Germany is angular Merkel on
the way out
[Music]
David McAllister welcome to conflict
zone
thank you let's talk first if we may
about the migrant issue the situation
may have eased in the sense that far
fewer people are coming to Germany and
the rest of Europe but the political
fallout is killing the CDU it's killing
your government isn't it this issue
isn't killing my party this issue is a
malade major challenge for Germany and
the whole European Union the numbers
have come come down since 2015 but of
course we have to make sure that the
numbers stay at the level they are now
and this means that we have to
understand in the European Union but in
a Europe in the Schengen area with out
border controls our external borders are
the European external borders they
protect them better yeah but you say
it's not killing you the coalition
almost fell apart in the summer didn't
it intense squabbling over refugees
intense squabbling over the violence the
country's intelligence chief scandal
after scandal the SPD party Social
Democratic Party Lars King bar called it
a state of permanent crisis so it is
killing your party well undoubtedly we
have gone through some turbulent weeks
and months in Germany
I welcome about the free coalition
parties the cdu/csu EMA Social Democrats
have now agreed to concentrate on the
issues and this is exactly what German
citizens are expecting the compromise I
mean the fact is that by the standards
of your government the far-right AFD is
looking pretty strong in stables
well if you're in politics you always
have to be ready to find compromises and
if you're on a coalition government with
free parties you have to be ready also
to strike deals and find compromises you
know what I said about the AFD but this
is what daily governmental work is about
is growing it's strong it's stable in
some poses the second party in Germany
yes and undoubtedly this is a worrying
development I sit down a month ago you
said the threat of the FT didn't worry
you so much because 85% of Germans
didn't vote for radical right-wing
well that's a matter of fact 15% for the
FT in the polls is for me far too high
and I wish
that the numbers would come down and I
seriously believe that a German
Bundestag without the alternative of the
doctrine would be a better place than
with the AFD but in the driver narrative
they're driving the debate about
immigration the fact that it was only 15
percent of Germans who voted for them is
neither here nor there they're in charge
of the narrative one thing they're not
in charge of the narrative these people
in the AFD are giving very very simple I
would say simplistic answers to very
complex questions and we have to make
clear about politics is more than just
giving simple answers you have to work
hard and that's why I welcome up the
government has now finally decided to go
back to work to concentrate on the
serious issues what we have to avoid is
internal party fighting and also
internal coalition fighting it's normal
to look for compromises in a coalition
but what we experienced in the last few
weeks wasn't very helpful and the only
party which really benefited was for aft
you right there that's why the better
work we deliver the better we can make
possible but the aft will go down in
numbers again well you are looking then
for complicated answers but while you're
doing that a million cdu/csu voters have
defected to the aft so it's not going
very well for you is it well if the aft
is in the polls now about between sixty
and seventy percent one thing is obvious
they're getting voters from all parties
yes they're getting voters from our
party but also hundreds of thousands of
people who voted for the Social
Democrats at velocity elections also
voted for the aft so the aft is a
challenge for the whole political system
in Germany not only for my party and
you've been far too complacent about
them in the past last year one of the
AFD founders alexander gallant went so
far as to say that germans should be
proud of what their armies did during
the two world wars he was pushing the
boundaries and he got away with it
didn't he well what the AFD leadership
is doing they're pushing the boundaries
week by week and I think this is
appalling
and clearly the AFT has shown in the
last few weeks and months but now they
are not drawing borders which are
necessary between the radical right and
the conservative right and that's why
the aft is responsible and I am for a
very serious debate with the AFD making
clear that we will not accept right-wing
populism nationalism and racism in
Germany
you may not accept it but look at the
effect on Germany recent polls by Forza
one of Germany's most respected polling
organizations reports that more than one
in four Germans now believe Islam
arouses fear so by pressing that fear
button they really are changing the
political mood in Germany whether you
like it or not millions of Muslim
citizens in Germany are now an integral
part of our society these people will in
for Germans think Islam arouses fear is
that a happy state of affairs and that's
why we have to make clear but the huge
majority of Muslims living in Germany
Germany are playing according to the
rules are following the law and that we
have to make be about those who are not
following our rules and our laws will
have to be taken to court like any other
German citizens I want to see a
integrative I want to see an inclusive
German society and this includes now
millions of Muslim citizens who have
come from other parts of the world to
Germany to stay in Germany and they are
welcome to become German citizens and
there's this country is also their
country how do you make that clear when
your Chancellor Angela Merkel is already
looking more and more like a wounded
animal isn't it she lost a key ally when
her choice to lead a parliamentary group
was booted out last month
very embarrassing defeat for her because
she had made a special plea saying that
folk ekkada was crucial to the stability
of her government she lost so we have to
assume that her government is less
stable as a result of that to take her
at her own words much less stable
Falkirk Aida was voted out as leader the
cdu/csu parliamentary group in the
Bundestag was a surprise this is unusual
for my political party but it was a huge
defeat for her person herself said that
this was a defeat but this happens in a
democracy the parliamentary party
decided to vote for Ralph bring cows now
Ralph bring cows has been the vice
chairman of the cdu/csu group in the
last year's and he announced that he
wouldn't change the policy of the group
and he's also been very supportive of
Angela Merkel so yes you can't spin it
as a success
David McAllister actress is a major
defeat for
as good to Athena the EU budget
commissioner said she's a lame duck now
he said the six days ago
Merkel is for Chancellor of the Federal
Republic of Germany a vulnerable stream
leave honourable charity will presumably
run again as CDU chair woman at our
party conference at the beginning of
december i would support this ralph
Franca's has endorsed a candidate sure
so we have a change in the leadership of
Sidious new group this might mean a
slight change in the way politics are
presented that the German Bundestag it
might be a fresh start for the cdu/csu
group but I believe that they wanted and
if your party does badly in regional
elections in HESA and Bavaria it's gonna
be real pressure on her to go weren't
that well first of all we've got to wait
until the elections actually take place
I don't times the other day I can
imagine the entire senior party
leadership coming under pressure to
resign and that includes Merkel so the
vultures are gathering around her aren't
they well you were concentrating on the
regional elections in Bavaria on the
14th of October and a fortnight later in
Essen and they may we'll see what the
polls are showing is fatter the lower
level of course but still the CDU in
Harrison and the CSU in Bavaria by far
the strongest party and we will probably
lead the two governments once again this
in this in these federal states but of
course we will have to look for
coalition partners look we've been going
through a number of very turbulent weeks
and German politics undoubtedly luck is
running out isn't it the momentum is
drifting away from her she no longer has
the momentum she looks vulnerable she
looks weak she can't get her way in the
party she can't get her allies voted in
I don't know what it's like in other
countries but I can tell you for Germany
about ups and downs and politics are
nothing very special of course I would
like to see us doing better in the polls
at the moment but I'm very sure once
we're back on track doing serious work
in Berlin up in the government than the
approval rates will go up again in June
agreed a migration compromise inside the
EU again with it had many holes in it
rescued migrants would be sent to
control centers across Europe but no one
agreed on the locations so nobody knows
where that's going to happen or how it's
going to happen no country would be
forced to have these control centres
easy to get an agreement when there are
no demands being made on any of the
people who sign up to it isn't it the
agreements meaningless isn't it I
believe that the migration crisis can
only be solved at a European level not
at a national it's not being soldered
well it's the largest challenge for us
in the European Union it's a challenge
which will stay for years and even
decades what we have to do now is to
protect our external borders better we
will step up front X up to ten thousand
font X servants until 2020 we have to
fight the root causes of migration
especially in Africa and we have to get
our priorities right in national
legislation what we can do about those
people who come to Europe who are
fleeing from war civil war who are
afraid of their lives can actually find
humanitarian protection but on the other
hand those people who are coming for
economic reasons but our acclaiming
asylum will have to be sent back to the
countries whether you the UN is not
impressed with the so-called deals that
you've had it expressed serious concern
last month about the so called deal and
warned that proposals being discussed
risk compromising human rights and
humanitarian principles but what we have
is you don't care about those we have to
break the business model of the
smugglers it cannot be that criminals
decide who can actually reach Europe if
they put people taking their money onto
boats onto a very dangerous risky trip
across the Mediterranean but the UN says
these measures are nothing more than an
attempt to regain the political
initiative from the far-right well
Europe has shown humanitarian
responsibility in the last year's we
have taken hundreds of thousands
millions of refugees and we will
continue to show our humanitarian
responsibility but one thing is clear
not
one from Africa can come to Europe so we
have to cooperate better with
neighboring countries and the EU and
Turkey struck a deal which solved the
migration route on the Western Balkan
route and now we have to find similar
compromise with the countries in Africa
this is not easy but we are talking for
instance with Egypt how we can cooperate
better how come on to Egypt a bit later
but but your policy of allowing 1.4
million migrants to come to Germany was
the biggest recruitment tall tall tool
that the AFT could possibly have had and
far-right parties around Europe wasn't
it across 22 European countries support
for populist radical right party has
never been higher in 30 years that's
quite an achievement and that's
traceable right back to your of your
humanitarian policies isn't it 2015 was
a unique situation since them is a
unique situation already on their way
and Germany and other countries like
Austria Sweden the Netherlands showed
responsibility in a very challenging
situation now since then the numbers
have gone down by nearly 90 percent mr.
MacAlister portion people dying on the
mediterranean route is actually going up
it's actually going up as the UN said
now we have one in every 18 people who
are crossing the central Mediterranean
dying before it was 1 in 42 so there's
nothing to feel complacent about oh
happy about or pleased about is there
with the policy because of the Porsche
people dying is kind of a situation in
2015 and since then we have brought the
numbers down but still every single
human being who dies in the military is
one too much that's why we have to break
the business case of the smugglers we
should prevent people from actually
getting on these boats and that's why we
should decide who can come to Europe or
not if it's possible on African
territory in northern Africa but of
course only according to our very high
standards when it comes to human rights
and the dignity of human let's let's
talk about that because you have been
calling for a Marshall Plan for Africa
but which which sounds great but the
endemic corruption of some of your
target countries let's take New Zealand
Sudan for instance seems to have been
totally ignored by the EU
I mean attempts to make aid conditional
on stopping the human smuggling may
actually have made the situation worse
haven't they because you're dealing with
countries that are themselves part of
the problem governments repressive
governments that are part of the problem
why people are leaving you're not
changing the governments you're paying
the oppressors aren't you I've been to
Africa nine times since 2014 and
something which I am very convinced of
is the future of Europe is very closely
linked to the future of our neighboring
continent Africa and what we need to
develop is a new policy on Africa which
will combine elements of our foreign
policy off on trade policy our
neighborhood policy and our development
policies that deal with an eruption the
massive corruption and the repression
how does that do I welcome the attempts
of the German government and other
governments to actually talk about a
Marshall Plan not for Africa but with
Africa what we need is a debate on a
level with the African countries and of
course some African countries are doing
better than others but what we have to
do is fight the root causes and that
means in the first case if people are
leaving Africa because we didn't have a
perspective because the youth
unemployment is so high if people can't
feed their families if they don't have
jobs that's what we have to do but of
course we also have to improve the track
record of African governments when it
comes to the rule of law democracy and
operations you're not I mean as
transparency international reported in
July while roughly 43 percent of
Africans are living in poverty 50
billion dollars worth of stolen assets
leaves the continent every year
well yeah it's like pouring water into a
basin that doesn't have a plug in it all
you have to money just goes out well you
have to engineer in Africa you have
countries which are doing better and you
have countries with a negative track
with the so called cartoon process for
instance yes state shutters Sudan
Eritrea Somalia Ethiopia South Sudan all
taking part in EU initiatives all
themselves responsible for brutal
repression that is making people leave
so you are dealing with the oppressors
and as I said before funding them we
can't choose our governments we can't
choose our leaders in Africa we have to
deal with those who are there but one
thing is key and European policy has
always been like this it's more for more
and less for less and those countries
which are following our European values
when it comes to democracy the rule of
law human dignity if you look for
instance in Africa for instance Tunisia
I believe is a success story it's a very
partial success it's a partial success
story but look if we had the approach in
Europe but we would only be talking and
dealing with like-minded countries we
would very soon be reduced to Australia
New Zealand South Korea and Japan it's
with like-minded countries it's doing
things that work well it does the
difference isn't it it's doing things
that actually produce the result you
want
but you haven't produced the result you
want well rome wasn't built in a day
dealing with the african continent it's
getting poured into these countries and
going into the hands of repressive
government you know it I know it but we
both know it and we know that this has
to stop and we have to fight corruption
in Africa but if you're trying to tell
me
but we shouldn't cooperate at all with
African countries I didn't say that I
didn't say that our level this is what
you're trying to no it isn't I'm trying
to say you need to do things results you
want so lovely so you agree that we have
to deal with those governments which are
in power but of course we will support
those super countries with strong civil
societies and those political forces who
will be able to give African people the
same benefits we enjoy in Europe David
McCarthy you talk about corruption in
Africa but the EU has conspicuously
failed to deal with corruption inside
the block itself inside the EU Europe's
Europe's dirty little secret is that
it's not nearly as transparent as
it likes to portray itself if you look
at this year's banking scandals as much
as thirty billion dollars of Russian and
former Soviet money it's got mean
laundered through the Estonian bank of
branch of Danske Bank Dutch Bank ing
also forced to pay seven hundred and
seventy five million euros a Latvian
bank actually had to be closed because
it was funding North Korea's nuclear
program so people are exploiting the
enormous loopholes that have been left
open in the European banking system why
have you left open these loopholes well
look I'm not responsible for loopholes
in the European banking system these
examples you have given your senior
member these exams which have been given
are in acceptable and it's up to
national governments and the European
institutions if they are responsible to
close these loopholes but just coming
back to what you said beforehand
the European Union is by large and by
far the biggest donor of development aid
in the world and those who are
criticizing the European Union outside
the European Union should always ask
themselves what they are doing so even
if we still have to do more every one
Africa we still have to do more for the
science at least other parts of the
world could try to do a little more and
full of the European I have sold
yourselves to a higher standard here
many more of these banking scandals are
out there do you know how many full-time
staff the European Banking Authority has
working directly on money laundering
well I'm happy to be on this show to
find out now
to two people three full-time staff it's
a joke isn't it it's not serious
you're totally a massive blind eye to
money laundering within the European
well I can't comment on this issue but
I'll be very sure to double-check these
figures I guess but you also have
probably people on the national level
who are also reported responsible for
this but I don't want to protect anyone
here Monday Lord ring is a serious
offense and of course the European Union
and its member states has to work very
hard that this doesn't repeat itself
according to Transparency International
key European countries members of the
OECD anti-bribery convention are failing
to implement it this is one of the main
instruments for fighting global
cross-border corruption if you look at
their findings Spain little or no
enforcement France limited enforcement
Ireland little or no enforcement Czech
Republic little or no enforcement
Austria little or no enforcement is that
a happy state of affairs well it
certainly isn't a happy state of affairs
and I simple cracy isn't and I think
that these figures you just mentioned
should be an initiative will should be
something which national governments
should take very seriously and I'm also
happy to address these issues here in
the European Parliament mr. mcallister
standards aren't helped when European
judges allow MEP s like you to hide the
details of their expenses instead of
practicing transparency the European
Court of Justice has just ruled it would
be a breach of any peace privacy if they
had to provide the public with details
of expenses invoices repeats you know
like normal people but the MEP s won't
do that well this is a debate message
the European Court of Justice this is a
debate which has been where we're now
following for several years in this
European Parliament the member states
have different national standards you
have some countries where MEP s have to
reveal every detail of the monthly
allowance they get in other countries
this is different four thousand four
hundred minus 16 euros per MEP in
general expenses which they don't have
to account have any problem if the rules
were changed on this issue but in the
moment this is the situation that but
this is something reach will have to be
decided between the group leaders and
the presidency and I would be falling to
follow any rule which is given on this
issue now in this decision do anything
except to encourage dishonesty and
wastage it can't can it it's a step
backwards for the European Union which
is trumpeting its values around the
world and then allows people to get away
with a lot
account its accountability hasn't its
basic accountability that is being
ignored here yes but if I'm correctly
informed we have a very similar
situation in the German Bundestag and I
never fought heard criticism about
German members of the German Bundestag
weren't accountable for what they are
doing they get this monthly allowance
and for this money they can spend it on
their office on newspapers on books on
whatever and the question is if you are
supposed to document this or not if we
start documenting this which if this is
decided I would certainly do you would
of course create an enormous new
bureaucracy but somebody would have to
control what is the money being spent on
and are these actually true figures or
not you talked earlier a little bit
about Egypt aid to Egypt I believe EU
assistance stands at about 1.3 billion
euros and there's a new allocation for
2017 to 2020 which is between 432 and
538 million euros I think those are the
figures the european parliament has
passed resolution after resolution
condemning the human rights abuses that
have taken place in egypt and yet it
continues to pour money and it doesn't
use the muscle it has to rein in these
abuses which go on day after day people
are being tortured people are being
sentenced to death mass trials with five
minutes per hearing show the trials that
do not live up to international
standards so why keep paying the
oppressors in Egypt why not use the
muscle you have to stop this kind of
thing set benchmarks but you don't the
European Parliament has repeatedly
sharply criticized human rights
violations and rightly so because we
believe human rights are universal they
apply to all human beings not only to us
in Europe the European Parliament is a
worldwide known advocate for global
human rights that's my point you just
talk you talk about it don't do anything
no that is not correct because dealing
with these countries as I tried to
explain to you we have an approach more
for more and less for less those
countries who follow our way forward
towards for human rights the rule of law
and democracy will get
more support than others but these keep
on getting supporting some laughing
allow these regime in Cairo and we have
to accept this regime we have to
strengthen civil society the opposition
and other responsible political forces
who are in favor of more democracy and
the rule of law but in the meantime what
isn't in working we have in McAlester
you know it is Ematic channel's open
what is the alternative
not to deal a to come and shift cut the
money back set benchmarks get it to
milestones to achieve they get the next
yes and then people like me will be
sitting in your program and you will be
criticizing us why aren't we not talking
and dealing with the Africans once again
we can't choose our negotiation partners
turkey for enters a difficult
negotiation negotiation partner and
still be struck a deal with Turkey and
since then the numbers are coming down
and of course we have to see that
countries in northern Africa and the
Middle East are also sharing a lot of
burden when it comes to migration waves
and the refugees
I mean criticizing Turkey is for one
thing and I've always criticized the
political situation in Turkey for good
reasons but on the other hand I have to
see that this country has sheltered
millions of refugees coming from
neighboring countries we have to end it
there David McAllister thanks very much
for the pleasure
[Music]
you
[Music]